all right speaking of football games
can't wait to see you know we need a
feature it's friday how about can't wait
to see what can't we wait to see
this weekend shireen i'll let you go
first
well i can't wait to see how many how
many fans the cowboys have in this
stadium and we only had two games last
week that had fans in the stadium was
very limited
jerry jones for whatever reason and he
was asked about it twice again today
won't say how many fans they expect they
put single game tickets on sale this
week which tells me that a lot of
seasoned ticket holders including one of
my neighbors
opted out and are not going to go to the
games because of the kofit rest so how
many fans are they going to end up with
i think he wants 20 to 25 000 but he's
really downplayed it and he'll
he said well you'll see when we release
the attendance
at the end of the game so we will see
when they release the attendance
texas is about to open back up to 75
percent does he expect to have 75
at their next home game so it's going to
be interesting to see how this climbs
with the cowboys because you know
you know he wants to have fans in the
stands at the stadium with as much money
as he makes
6 000 last night in cleveland somehow a
fight still broke out i worry about how
much you can effectively keep people
separate
and you make a great point about single
game tickets being available because
some teams believe that having fans
present
is about making your season ticket
holders
happy and giving them the chance to come
if the local
ordinances allow them to be there and
some teams would just as soon
have the local ordinance say you can't
have fans here because it's not a
money-making proposition but
if there's 20 25 000 i don't know maybe
they end up breaking even or at least
making a little money on top of that for
what it costs to open and operate the
stadium
all day long i'm looking forward to
seeing hashtag tommy
his home opener for the tampa bay
buccaneers the carolina panthers come to
town
this is a game that they should win this
is a game that he should play well in
this is a game
that he should erase that memory of
going on the road to new orleans and
losing he was an underdog for the first
time in years
and it proved to be accurate lost by 11
points
i want to see how he recovers i want to
see what kind of passion what kind of
fire
and i'm just curious i mean if they if
they lose this game
it really is panic time for the
buccaneers they shouldn't lose it
i just want to see him get back on the
horse and get things rolling and create
the sense
that they are going to be a team to be
reckoned with as the season unfolds
yeah a lot of analytics people have
already written off tom brady saying see
we told you wasn't very good last year
he's not very good this year the
buccaneers are overrated they're not
going to be very good they need to come
out
and dispel all that and play well this
week and if they don't play well as you
said we're hitting that panic button and
we're hitting it more than we're hitting
it for the cowboys because they're in a
really good division
i also want to see clyde edwards hilaire
more of clyde edwards please had over
130 yards rushing
of course didn't do much in the passing
game had no receptions
didn't pass block that much he was in
there to run he did that he did it
really well he just
adds another dimension to the chiefs it
seems like forever since the chiefs
played i mean it
i you forget about them because they
play that opening game on thursday night
and and here they are they're not ranked
high in offense you know when you start
looking at
where they rank their 15th in total
offense but we know they're much better
than that
i expect to see a lot of good offense
this week from the chiefs
and for everything that went well for
clyde edward delaire last week and the
kansas city chiefs there was talk
yesterday about him being better
in the goal line making the blockers
right
and getting to the hole and getting
through it and scoring
when he's down there and i get the
impression that his goal line duties
could be in jeopardy if he can't get it
done they find somebody else on that
depth chart who can get it done so
not all was great for clyde edward
solaire in his debut they think he can
be better
at the goal line all right i can't wait
to see allegiant stadium
aka the roomba aka the death star
here's john gruden talking about the
nickname of his new stadium
i think it's a cool name for our stadium
i don't give a damn about star wars
that's what we're calling our stadium
and
i don't care what anybody else thinks
it's a cool stadium it's a great name
and we just got to play good when we're
in there
yeah here's the thing anybody who knows
anything about star wars knows that it
doesn't end well
for the death star and as i pointed out
when mark davis christened at the death
star
patrick mahomes is going to be the guy
who puts a couple of proton torpedoes
and
proton torpedoes into the exhaust port
whether the colts
or your vikings start out 0-2 we made a
big deal about philip rivers
yes yeah you've been hanging no you've
been talking to sims too much
your vikings i can refer to them as your
cowboys if you want me to
i'll do that okay fair play all right go
ahead
okay uh whether the cults of the vikings
start at 012 because we saw
the colts sign phillip rivers and we
thought okay
they're going to be the team that
contends that wins the division title a
lot of people picked them to win that
division title and
they didn't look very good in the first
week same with the vikings they commit
to kirk
cousins long term and look what happens
they lose that first game and really
weren't competitive in that game it got
away from him in a hurry
got away from him early so both of these
teams need a win
and both of them might be in trouble if
they don't get that win
this week so one of them is going to
start owen 2.
phillip rivers threw three interceptions
to the vikings when he was playing for
the chargers last december not that long
ago grand scheme of things
but it was a chargers home game which
meant it was a vikings
home game because the place was full of
vikings fans it's got a dif
different vibe this time 2500 colts fans
there and there probably will be
colts fans not vikings fans but i want
to see what rivers can do against that
new look vikings defense the key is the
pass rush
they need something out of yannick and
gawkway he has said this week
he needs to provide that spark he's
familiar with the colts he's got six and
a half sacks
in eight career games against the colts
they need
something to put some heat on philip
rivers because they have that young
secondary you can't get away with a
young secondary
if you don't have some pressure up front
it's a huge game for both teams
and either team that loses is going to
slip into that hole that's going to be
hard to get out of they want to win
their division
especially for the vikings after losing
at home last week to the green bay
packers
all right i am looking forward to seeing
the guy who
transferred from your texas a m
kyler murray the heisman trophy winner
the number one overall pick in the draft
the latest second year
quarterback to begin the process of
taking the nfl by storm
i wish the cardinals had a higher
profile i wish
that more people could see calamari play
live
i wish they were in prime time more
often they will be sooner than later
with kyler murray doing the kinds of
things he did last week
what's going to happen when that front
seven
of the washington football team starts
chasing him around
can they catch him can they slow him
down can they minimize the number of
times he throws to the andre hopkins
will this be a game plan week where
washington tries to take deandre hopkins
away and calamari has to go elsewhere
and it'll be interesting to see if he
does that because
you know one of the concerns in houston
deshawn watson threw the ball
too often to deandre hopkins looked too
often looked held the ball too long
to wait for hopkins to get open will
murray just throw to the open guy even
if it means
far fewer than 16 targets this week for
deandre hopkins so
i'm fascinated to see what he can do
especially going against the defense
that had eight sacks last week of carson
wentz
can kylo murray be more elusive and can
he continue to avoid getting hit shireen
he just negates the pass rush so well
i mean nick bosa i think we would all
agree is one of the best pass rushers in
the nfl and
he wasn't there last week he just
couldn't get to kyler murray because he
eludes the sack and he doesn't take
those big hits he gets out of bounds he
gets down he does all the right things
and he
hey by the way he draws penalties two 15
yard penalties
that were extremely questionable when
guys kind of rolled over the top of him
and might have grazed him
but he didn't get hit that hard and he
still drew those two
uh penalties so yeah he's just great at
avoiding the sack i i would highly doubt
washington has eight sacks this this
week
after they had eight of carson wentz
last week but that pass rush is really
good we're gonna get to see it they just
keep
rolling those first rounders in there to
rush the quarterback
all right my last one mike is whether
the lions will blow
another fourth quarter lead they just
seem to do it
almost every single week at least on a
regular basis
they were up 10 points with just over
four minutes to play last week blew that
lead deandre swift
drops the ball in the end zone that
would have pulled it out anyway
they've blown 11 fourth quarter leads or
tied in the fourth quarter under matt
patricia and they just seem to keep
doing it time after time after time
and if they're going to be a playoff
team they've got to be able to hold
those leads i know lions fans are going
to get really nervous
if they're only up ten or seven or three
in the fourth quarter they
because they can't hold the lead they
just for whatever reason they can't do
it so they need to get up by
by a lot to be able to have a big
cushion there in the fourth quarter
i rarely make guarantees but i'll make
this guarantee the lions
will not blow a fourth quarter lead this
week because they won't have
a fourth quarter lead to blow this week
you got to have the lead
before you blow the lead they're going
to lambeau field to take on the packers
and i just think
the way it went down last week for the
lions it's going to be so hard to pivot
to going into aaron rodgers house and
it's going to be so
strange i think to be in that building
with the bleachers not the seats it's
just going to be a
a bizarre feeling for everybody but not
for aaron rodgers i think revenge tour
continues
and he's going to pick them apart and
they won't have to worry about blowing a
lead i want to mention one other thing
real
briefly though what you said about kylie
murray drawing penalties
he's the opposite of cam newton cam
newton can't get flags because he's such
a giant
guys hit him and the officials don't
flinch
calamari so little they feel like they
have to protect him so yeah the flags
are coming out you're picking up 15
yards of field position at a time
that's an extra benefit for being kyler
murray all right the last thing i'm
looking forward to
this weekend it's the home opener for
the pittsburgh steelers in a pandemic
and i know from watching steelers games
over the last 20 years
the moment that people start leaving
whether it's halftime
whether it's late in the game you got to
put sunglasses on
because those yellow seats are
piercing and anytime we see the stands
this weekend it is going to be even more
jarring than it was
all of week one it is bright when you
drive through
the fort pit tunnels in pittsburgh you
see the yellow seats
at heinz field now it's one of the great
skylines to witness as you cross the
fort pit bridge
but you're distracted by this yellow
that is just glowing there
at empty hines field and uh that's going
to be a strange sight when the broncos
and the steelers play
on sunday and i i i can't get used to
the empty stadiums
last night the 6 000 in cleveland's fine
i just have
something there other than nothing i
can't get used shireen
to nothing being there in the stands and
no limbo leap in green bay no terrible
towels in pittsburgh it is going to be a
strange
sight in all these stadiums and who
knows how those yellow seats the sun
glare off of those seats you know at att
stadium when when they play those three
o'clock games three o'clock local time
and that sun comes through
that roof it can it really gets in the
quarterback size
the receiver's eyes or depending on
which way they go
but we could see the same thing in
pittsburgh with as glaring as those
yellow seats are
yeah it's going to be a strange weekend
but hopefully as the season unfolds
people can
safely continue going to games i i i'm
not going to make any predictions we
just hold out hope the good news is
we're on the brink of week two we're
actually into week two
and the covet 19 said i don't want to
jinx it but
so far so good hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports